now they have boyfriends and real lives
and all that stuff but yeah they have
grown up right before our very eyes
michelle and barack obama's daughters
are all grown up and the couple well
they're now empty nesters
bye on tuesday the former first lady
stopped by the ellen degeneres show and
opened up about saying bye to her
daughter's 20 year old sasha and 23 year
old malia after they both moved out of
the family home
again
after quarantining together during the
height of the pandemic it was an extra
special treat to have them that little
bit of time because being with them as
adults
is it's fun i mean i love them at every
age that was sasha's graduation from
high school
she is in college and they are doing
well and
they are just amazing young women
michelle says it's scary how fast
they've grown and noted that they've
come a long way since fangirling over
the jonas brothers
[Music]
now it's less joe bros and more
real-life boyfriends they love you
brought them to see the jonas brothers
now they're bringing grown men home uh
before it was just like a pop band now
they have boyfriends and real lives and
all that stuff but yeah they have grown
up right before our very eyes and the
becoming author says that she made sure
to instill the right values in her girls
both while living in the white house and
out
i listened to what my mother said when
she was raising us she says i'm not
raising babies i'm raising real people
to be out in the world and i kept that
in mind with the girls i mean they
wouldn't always be in that bubble of the
white house so they had to learn how to
make their beds they had to learn how to
drive they had to learn how to be
compassionate independent responsible
people
so that they enter the world as
responsible compassionate capable people
and i think they are amazing young women
because of that now fans of michelle can
watch viola davis's portrayal of the
former flotus on showtime's new series
first lady
they want to turn me into a black martha
stewart
i will pick my team choose my causes
understood e.t recently chatted with the
oscar winner about playing michelle on
the small screen and she admitted she
had some nerves about it it had to be
like daunting for you all because you
are taking on some of the most powerful
most enigmatic you know first ladies
that we've ever had absolutely
terrifying but you know what you're
terrified whenever you start a job
because you're afraid you're going to be
found out that's a big imposter
but with michelle obama it's like
everyone has ownership over michelle
obama i mean her book came out it was
like a best-sellers list
everyone knows what she looks like what
she sounds like but her hair looks
you know and there's a
sister bond there
for me
you know that sort of girl code that's
my 11 year old is always like girl code
mama girl code so it's a girl code it's
like i i gotta make the sister look good
as for the real life michelle she wasn't
just dishing out life updates on her
daughters
she also revealed how her hubby is
enjoying life outside of the white house
pretty good at golf now
he's doing a lot of golf
not so good at picking up after himself
he had a lot of help doing that yeah he
thinks he's good at it at it but he he
had a lot of help you're right he's got
a little worse at that and while viola
davis is playing michelle there's
another superstar gunning for the chance
to someday play barack
drake how do you feel about drake
playing that role i don't i don't know
that he's got the ears for it
i mean they're both cute yes yeah
they're both cute but he'd have to sort
of do something with his ears
[Music]
you